[موسيقى]
مجوز الاخبار اهلا بكم الجرادي بالمسيبونا
روس وامريكيون مباحثات في مدينه اسطنبول
التركيه وقال نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
مصادر القلق بالنسبه للطرفين وقال الرئيس
الروسي الذيب الاتصالات الاستخباريه
مستمره مع واشنطن بطلبا من الجانب
الامريكي
على اطراف المشاركه في عمليه التسويه بشان
الحرب في اوكرانيا سيتعينوا عليها القبول
بالحقائق على الارض وفق تعبير
قال الرسول
صيغه بلاده للسلام تشمل عشره نقاط بين
استعاده وحده الاراضي الاوكرانيه اضافه
الى امن الطاقه وعوده اسرى الحرب
والمبعدين المحتجزين على اراضي روسيا
قال وزير الخارج
الولايات المتحده فرضت عقوبات على مسؤولين
روس ووكلاء سهموا في استمرار الحرب غير
القانونيه والقاتله في اوكرانيا
قالت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كرنجه
جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه 275 مليون دولار
تتضمن قدرات لتعزيز الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه في صدها جامعه المسيرات
الايرانيها
كشفت وثيقه للبنك المركزي الاوروبي ان وضع
سقف لاسعار الغاز في اوروبا قد يهدد
الاستقرار المالي ياتي ذلك وسط انقسام
الاوروبيين بشان فرض سعر للغاز حيث اعلنت
ست دول من الاتحاد وعرضتها لتوسيع نطاق
السقف ودعت الى نسمه اليه لتصحيح السوق
ذكرت وكاله انباء الاناضول ان الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان عقد اجتماعا في
اسطنبول مع الكسي ميلر رئيس اللجنه
الاداريه لشركه
عن شركه
خلال الاجتماع توريد الغزل الروسي الى
تركيا وامكانيه تاسيسه للغاز هناك
اخطتي مات في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
ثلاث قمم خليجيه خليجيه وصينيه خليجيه
وعربيه صينيه وشدد قاده الدول العربيه
المشاركون على اهميه تطوير العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه مع الصين لتشمل جميع
المجالات كما التزموا بالتنسيق في قضايا
تمثل مصالح مشتركه من نجاه قال الرئيس
الصيني لان الملفات المتبادله قوه دافعه
للعلاقات المشتركه اكد دعم بجيل للجانب
العربي في جاد حلول للقضايا الشركه في
المنطقه كما اشار الى بدايه مرحله جديده
في شراكه الصينيه الخليجيه العربيه
وفي كلمه خلال انطلاق اعمال القمه
الخليجيه الصينيه الاولى من نوعها بحضور
الرئيس سجن بينج قال ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان ان القمه تؤسس لما
وصفها بانطلاقه تاريخيه جديده لعلاقات
الصين بدول الخليج واكد ان دول المجلس
مجلس التعاون تولي اهميه قصوى للرفع من
مستوى الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
وفي افتتاح اعمال القمه الثالثه والاربعين
لقاده دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي في الرياض
شدد ولي العهد السعوديه الامير محمد بن
سلمان على اهميه التكامل بين دول مجلس
التعاون